they're running scared either you're
gonna be tough on putin or you're not
the only way to be tough on putin is to
sanction the energy companies uh
president zielinski of ukraine is
begging for it he's begging for things
and you know are we okay allowing people
to die in the streets of ukraine because
we're worried that russia will get mad
if we sanction their energy sector no we
should be teaching russia a lesson by
sanctioning their energy companies we
should be pulling them out of the
international banking system we should
be sending um arms to ukraine so they
can defend themselves and protect
themselves you know they desperately
need anti-air anti-tank javelin and
stinger missiles we should be sending
those over
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the former united states ambassador to
the united nations the former governor
of south carolina and someone who knows
a little something about international
relations ambassador nikki haley welcome
back to the reuben report thanks so much
great to be with you dave
well i'm glad to have you this week
because i've been telling my audience
for the last 10 days or so that it's
extremely hard right now to figure out
exactly what's going on in ukraine and
russia and of course
uh kamala harris did tell us that
ukraine's small russia big but i want to
see if we can give a little more
thoughtful analysis to that if possible
so first could you just give us sort of
a russia ukraine 101 a little bit of the
history some of the geopolitics what got
us to this moment and then we'll go from
there
well i think what got us to the moment
is we all know that the soviet union
fell and when it fell you know
russia apparently had borders and
ukraine had freedom and democracy and
what has happened is putin has decided
he's just going to ignore history he's
going to recreate it and in his mind he
thinks that it needs to go back to the
soviet union and so he believes that
ukraine is part of russia it's part of
the soviet empire and he's only taking
what is rightfully theirs
ukraine on the other hand is a
flourishing
democracy um where people appreciate
freedom it was knocking on putin's
doorstep he was worried that russians
were going to see the freedom that
ukraine's the ukrainians had and he
didn't want that to happen the lesson in
all of this dave is that when a an evil
dictator
thug says they're going to do something
we need to believe them putin said he
was going to take ukraine and he is
china said they were going to take hong
kong and they did putin says that he's
next going for poland and the baltics we
should believe it china says they're
going to get taiwan that's going to
happen iran says they're going to
destroy israel we need to start
understanding that when tyrants say
something we should believe them get in
front of it so that we don't see this
kind of bloodshed that's happening
because what's happening now is is
nothing short of a tragedy
is this one of the things that we
discussed in our original interview say
six or eight months ago where
if we don't if the united states does
not lead does not say hey we have red
lines that you can't cross
say there are things that you cannot do
if we don't do it that the world just
kind of goes to hell in the handbasket
it doesn't mean we do everything right
all the time but pretty much without us
nato doesn't function other countries
don't sort of stand up for what's right
yeah i think it was very clear to me at
the united nations that
whether countries like the us or not
they want us to lead they would much
rather follow the united states and
follow china or russia any day of the
week and you know what i saw is when we
speak the world listens when we act the
world follows who we are the world wants
to be and so it doesn't mean we have to
go to war but it means that we need to
speak and speak loudly and we need to
make sure we do it in the name of
freedom and we do it in the name of
peace and what we need to be saying
loudly now is
you know europeans thought that if they
were nice to russia that russia would
leave them alone and what you find out
is when you sleep with the devil the
devil owns you europeans became 40
dependent on russia on russian oil
russia is a one industry country their
whole livelihoods is surrounded by
energy and the energy industry and so
what europe has to do now is they have
to become independent of russian oil
poland and lithuania have already done
that they're getting theirs from
australia um the united states should
not be taking russian oil we could open
up the keystone pipeline and that would
take up the oil that we're getting from
them but also we need to double down on
fracking we need to export liquefied
natural gas we need to really start to
understand this is a national security
issue because while a lot of people
think this is just ukraine
a million people have migrated out of
ukraine into all of those european
countries especially poland right now
the entire european region is going to
be disrupted and we're all going to feel
that and so
this is about
being smart and realizing where we are
and the fact that we need to be doing
something if you see the death that's
happening in the streets of ukraine
um don't think that's over there that
very well could be us that's not saying
you know any time there is a free
democracy there's a tyrant ready to take
it um we've seen that with israel for a
long time you're now seeing that with
ukraine you're going to see it with
taiwan the united states has to figure
out what they want to be when they lead
and i think we are always right when we
lead on the side of freedom so you
briefly mentioned sanctions there i'm
sure you saw the clips last week where
jan saki basically was saying you know
we have these incredible sanctions
sanctions like you've never seen before
and then just hours later i think it was
our deputy energy secretary who said oh
but it won't affect the energy sector of
russia's economy i mean do you sense
that the people that are in charge right
now from biden to the spokesman to the
rest of them that they have a sense of
really what's going on here i mean
they're running scared they're running
scared either you're gonna be tough on
putin or you're not the only way to be
tough on putin is to sanction the energy
companies uh president zielinski of
ukraine is begging for it he's begging
for things and you know are we okay
allowing people to die in the streets of
ukraine because we're worried that
russia will get mad if we sanction their
energy sector no we should be teaching
russia a lesson by sanctioning their
energy companies we should be pulling
them out of the international banking
system we should be sending um arms to
ukraine so they can defend themselves
and protect themselves you know they
desperately need anti-air anti-tank
javelin and stinger missiles we should
be sending those over you know
zielinski has said look you know send us
planes send us tanks send us anything
and you know the united states if we
stepped up and did it the rest of the
world would step up and do it 20
countries now have provided ukraine with
all sorts of military equipment and
things that they need but i'm worried
it's going to be too little too late
what would you say to the people who
make the argument that okay so you do
everything you can on sanctions we arm
the ukrainians we get some real alliance
worldwide alliance against putin
but this guy does have nukes we there's
questions about you know what his real
motives are and mental health and all of
that stuff that that if we do
basically what you're laying out there
that we then
we just don't know what's at the end of
the road or that if you pin this guy or
if you paint him into a corner america's
never been scared we can't be scared now
what you do is you fight evil wherever
it exists we need strength right now if
he's going to do something he's going to
do it regardless the best thing we can
do is continue to isolate
isolate him in the eyes of the world and
continue to make sure that we have all
of our allied partners together i mean
the thing that bothers me the most is
where are the arab countries they
haven't said a word through all this
this is an oil war they should
absolutely be saying something you know
why they're not saying anything is they
don't trust that america will lead and
they don't trust that putin will fail
and so the best thing the united states
could do is step up and lead and kick
putin where it hurts
might he use nukes yes but the bigger
question is
ukraine had nuclear production
and there was a treaty that was done
with us russia and ukraine where ukraine
gave up all of their nukes they were the
third largest holder of nuclear arms
and gave up all of their nukes in the
name of being free in the name of being
independent what does this say to
countries like iran
north korea those that were saying they
have to denuclearize why would they give
up their arms now when they know that
they really don't get the protections
they say they're going to get so what
you're going to see is the world is
going to start going back to the nuclear
arms they're going to start beefing up
because they're worried about when it's
going to happen to them if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell